so the kind of question of getting
cosmetic cultivate is when you've got
the right right brackets are just
showing it rapid is a notoriously lazy
right so therefore they like look I
don't have to write this whole thing
over again
I want to square all things you just put
brackets around which means whatever the
operation is due to the pole okay so in
fact this is shorthand right
this is shorthand for do the pronumerals
first sorry do the coefficients first
and then apprentice right
the order right Nikki babe it's getting
squared right
so therefore you do make you babe turns
negative eight what happens Susan it is
the kids of that that's great 8x8 that's
64 your coefficient and the way it's
done and then you move on to the credit
it's actually pretty straightforward
because the B times B do you already
have shorthand for that so let's be
squared and then you go it's okay so you
can see like brackets are not being
dramatic okay now let's just move on a
little bit because I know I got second
future this we always think this is the
best place when you're dealing with
algebraic fractions okay so we get
scared they get given a new name but the
same rules operate okay now before I go
on when you're doing the multiplication
here right you're going to multiply
numerators across and denominators you
can just multiply across just as if
they're separate I remember getting
madly confused when I first met these
cuz my teacher would say to me yeah if
you get given this you do 1 times 1 but
that's on the top then you 2 times 3 and
that's no big deal
and when I asked well then why can't I
do it for this like why isn't that 2
over fire they'd say oh well because you
can't do that but why like I was that
cute okay now there's a reason why it's
a really easy reason all of this stuff
it looks like there's one operation but
there's actually a whole border
operations that we do
you see shorthand for right Posadas
these two ties are division do you hear
that is division happening and then in
between every letter in every gun lock
there's more modification happening the
important thing is they all multiplying
and dividing like that's why we've kind
of lumped them together
multiplication sorry son again division
is just multiplication in Reverse right
they're really the same operation just
looked at from different opposite and so
therefore that's the reason why you can
string these all together now you can
see the problem here this is not all
multiplication and division just all
pile than a heap there's a plus sign in
the middle and it kind of interrupts
things right that's why you have to deal
with this guy do with that guy you've
got to do all of them well what would
you do in this case what do you need you
need something together get until John
to knock that need a common denominator
right because fractions are notoriously
anti-social so in order to get a common
base on those you get over 6
so you've got three over six two of the
six and now they can be rounded it's
okay whereas over here it's fine like
you don't need to get them into the same
base the multiplying dividing just fix
it up I just want it let's do this
example together before you do any
multiplying do the dividing that seems a
bit County to do because we hate the
violence it's tricky so it's actually
advantageous to you can anyone see one
there you can cross things off you can
make the numbers smaller like 8 times 15
you can do it but it's hard would you
not much prefer to do 8 times 5 it's
just gonna be easier right in the same
way you can get rid of some ends
immediately and then that just makes it
a lot simpler when we get left on the
top a 10 times 5 which is
40n okay we definitely do want to a test
update okay I know what's left on the
bottom it's just this is the nine
complicated look at me using leaving
whitespace we didn't need it at all okay
once you cancel the right stuff out it
becomes quite real
now here we remember that division is
what what do you do before we turn into
a product we flip it upside down okay so
this is in fact is equal to this okay
so channel your inner is the child
mister was a child like why why do that
seriously why we flip it upside down
okay so the first thing is like the
reason I do this is because just easier
on my brain I can use all the stuff I
already know about multiplication namely
wonder just a stranger cross off that
and cross off that that's great but it
doesn't us the deeper question what can
I do that like why am I allowed to just
change operations because I want to do
like so you can see mr. wizard how we're
not even satisfied with that which was
it's not that complicated
think about what thing you're not around
think about what that means that means
10/2 you can figure out a whole bunch of
different ways how many groups are too
can you get right what is 10 how like if
I get into two groups how big will the
group's big and I can come on and on and
save different ways of saying right in
other words half the group that's what
it's telling you to do okay so that's
why these are equivalent
not just because this
it says you can write multiple division
of trying to interact with each other in
this way so now we've converted it into
a product rather than a question because
questions of course cancer a whole bunch
of things what's left students it's just
the two and three and everything else is
gone